what was the hardest day of your life so
I run an online mastermind group for
entrepreneurs who are trying to grow
their businesses and I recently
challenged them to make a video about
what the hardest day of their lives were
and one of my members Jen who runs a
copywriting business submitted a video
that really moved me she got really
emotional in the video and i thought
that i would share it with you guys 21
lend some support to her but also to or
think there's some lessons in there that
you could probably relate to so i'm
going to roll the clip over to you yet
hi I'm Jen from you so much and I was
challenged by my mastermind group to
make a video about that most difficult
day that I've had um and when I got this
challenge I was a little bit nervous
because I couldn't help but think about
a video that i made that was basically
on that day i actually captured it in
video and i had been tentative to put it
up here on youtube because it was a
pretty vulnerable moment for me but the
reason why i actually captured on video
is because that I was always taught for
my mentor to capture things in the
moment right and I was totally thinking
to myself why I'm sure that as
entrepreneurs if you are out there
you've been in this situation where you
were totally devastated by something
that happened and you just sort of felt
like giving in and giving up and that's
kind of how I felt and so what basically
happened was I as you know I quit my job
a few months ago to start my own copy
writing business and the first couple
months things kind of weren't going very
well and one of the reasons why is
because I didn't just quit my job I
actually moved out of my house I was
having some personal difficulties at
home and so I decided to make a change
obviously a pretty big change to big
changes at the same time and so it was I
didn't anticipate how difficult it would
be to manage you know the emotional
difficulties it was going on with me
personally along with starting a new
business obviously I didn't really
anticipate what that was going to be
like and on top of that I sort of was
trying to do it all on my own that was
probably one of the biggest mistakes
that I made was you know besides leaning
a few very close friends of mine I
really sort of was like I can do this I
can do without asking for help or even
hardly even hardly told friends what was
going on with me and
that's probably the one thing that I
learned the most was to reach out to
other people and get support and
collaborate with other people to help
make success happened I sort of decided
consciously to make a big change and to
start doing more things for myself with
other people and ask for help and so I
had set up a mean that was going to
really help me out and I was really
ready for this meeting I was super
excited to umm you know make some big
changes and really step up and so I
prepared i prepared for this meeting and
for various reasons the meeting just
completely fell apart and i was just
devastated I was completely devastated
and the culmination of things that had
gone wrong and me feeling isolated him
alone it's just really hoping this one
meeting was just gonna completely help
my business which is you know you know
unrealistic as well but it was just I
was just so upset because it was kind of
a simple of a lot of things had gone
wrong for me over the past couple months
so here it is ah that moment that I
captured a video and maybe you can
relate with that moment yourself hit it
with things go like everything goes
wrong and you did everything to prepare
for it you know you know excited about
something and then it goes wrong it
sucks anyway I just thought it'd capture
the moment cuz I know how hard it is
when you are launched burner and you're
just try to do it all on your own and
you want everything to go right and you
work really hard when you have time a
set aside for something it just doesn't
happen I'm just pissed about it cuz I
was so excited because I want to make
some major progress in my business of it
like I just know this would have helped
and maybe it's good just remember this
wrote back and see what I could have
done better and let myself feel
frustrated cuz that's all I can do is be
frustrated right now and then I can move
on and go kick ass okay that's it so as
you can tell I was pretty upset and but
at the end I just like I knew I wasn't
just going to give in I was gonna make
the most of it and I'm wondering if
you've ever had a moment like that too
or you just kind of felt like throwing
in the towel love to hear your story if
you have one please share in the
comments below and hope you two are
going out there and kick
so I hope you guys enjoyed that I hope
there's something in there that you can
relate to and I'm hoping you can do two
things one show some support for Jen
leave a comment below let her know that
you support her you can go check out her
channel which is much on YouTube she
posed regularly to her channel as well
and 2 i'd love to know what the hardest
day of your life was if you want to
leave it in the comments below because i
think that other entrepreneurs who are
watching and see that comment that could
help inspire them to keep going because
nobody talks about how hard it is as an
entrepreneur we only talk about all the
good things you see it in the magazines
and the articles about people making
millions of dollars nobody talks about
how hard it is so support Jen leave a
comment subscribe to her channel and
also tell me about the hardest day of
your life in the comments below thank
you guys for watching continue to
believe and I'll see you soon